All right.
Excellent,
so thank you so much for joining us today.
Welcome to grand rounds at verily and today is a very important day for us.
Today is a day to think about our mission,
which I know drives everything that we do.
We know our mission is to make the world's health information useful so that
people can enjoy healthier lives and I know that all of us work incredibly hard.
We keep our heads down,
but if we keep our eyes on this mission,
then I think we're ultimately going to end up really affecting people's lives
and try to make a difference that we are trying to make every day.
The question is how do we actually achieve our mission and as I look around the
room and I see all of the different teams that come together,
this is a very special place that's got groups of people figuring out how do you
collect the next generation of information.
This information may be digital information and we were talking about that
earlier with Michael.
It may be molecular information and we have the latest and greatest technologies
that we can deploy.
It then becomes very important to organize this information.
Information that just lives in silos doesn't actually change care.
It doesn't help people.
And so the most important thing is how do we activate this information?
Getting into the hands of people,
patients,
providers,
and health systems.
And if we do that,
then we will achieve our mission.
Now,
the reason that we're starting in grand rounds at verily is as part of a big
effort to make sure that we understand our users and it's exciting today that
we're going to be kicking off this particular event and I'll hand it over to
bill to give you some background.
Thanks Jess.
Well,
welcome to the inaugural grand rounds and fairly
[inaudible].
As just said,
the intent of these sessions is really to connect us all with the patients,
researchers and clinicians that are a part of our lives.
And I know that many of you don't always have the opportunity to hear from the
patients voice.
So on a quarterly basis we'll bring in patients so we can hear their real life
stories,
understand their unmet needs and hopefully that'll really help us stay connected
to our mission.
Each session,
each quarter we'll have a different topic today the topic is Parkinson's disease
and 2017 marks,
the 200th anniversary of James Parkinson's.
First description of the disorder.
I think it's fair to say that maybe in the next 20 years we may make as much
progress in Parkinson's as had been made in the first 200 and I think we can
contribute to that.
Parkinson's disease is a common neurodegenerative disorder.
It's second only to Alzheimer's disease and prevalence affects about a million
Americans,
10 million people worldwide.
Most people think of Parkinson's disease as a movement disorder,
problems with slowness of movement,
stiffness of muscles,
shaking,
difficulty with gait and balance,
but it's really a multisystem disorder that affects so much more and causes many
symptoms for patients,
difficulty regulating blood pressure,
difficulty with sleep,
depression,
anxiety,
gastrointestinal issues,
and many other issues.
So it really is a multisystem disease.
And I think one that we're up to,
the challenge of tackling here at verily.
Many of you are aware of our emerging efforts in Parkinson's,
but I wanted to highlight why Parkinson's disease make sense for us to care
about and work on.
Certainly there are still knowledge gaps as I think you'll hear from our guests
that we can really help fill characterizing the disease better,
understanding how we measure the progression of the disease or the response to
treatments and we can all contribute to that and as we study this disease it
will simultaneously help us build out our capabilities in systems biology and
wearable sensors and algorithm development and so forth.
So it's really quite a nice match for our mission.
I think some of the specific programs that we have,
just so you're aware,
the new study watch is being used in our Parkinson's study in the Netherlands
and perhaps in other studies to come.
We think this will be very useful for tracking movement and function during the
patient's normal daily activities.
We also have liftware of course and lift where can be useful to cancel out
tremor that may interfere with feeding from Parkinsonian tremor and now with the
lift wear steady device can help Dyskinesia,
the involuntary movements that medication can cause in Parkinson's disease.
And then the Parkinson Mot,
that's the Dutch version of the personalized Parkinson project,
which is our longitudinal cohort study that we're kicking off in the Netherlands
with the goal of really understanding in a deep way what Parkinson's is to
advance treatments.
So I think a very interesting and important disorder that we care about and we
are extremely excited to have members of the Michael J.
Fox Foundation to help us better understand Parkinson's disease and learn what
it's like in terms of the impact on daily life.
For those who are not familiar with the Michael J.
Fox Foundation for Parkinson's research,
you know in its short history they say the only constant of the organization has
been its unflagging commitment to finding a cure for Parkinson's disease and put
itself out of business.
Michael was saying earlier that he wanted to go into business to go out of
business.
They launched the foundation in 2000 it quickly grew from a startup to the
world's largest nonprofit funder of Parkinson's drug development.
They've allocated more than $700 million since the inception of the
organization.
The New York Times has called the foundation,
the most credible voice on Parkinson's research in the world and it's widely be
being considered at the forefront of innovation.
They've established a pure level group of neuroscientists who prioritize,
manage and troubleshoot their research portfolio and they are sponsoring a
landmark biomarker study called Ppmi most recently to foundation has also
formally integrated policy and advocacy and to their work as well.
So a very impressive organization.
I've had the privilege of working with them pretty much since their inception.
Well,
let's bring out our guests.
Uh,
actually our first guest is already in the audience.
Debi Brooks,
uh,
is the co founder of the foundation.
Michael's employee number one,
I think they call you.
And uh,
presently the executive vice chairman of the organization
have a round of applause for Debbie [inaudible].
And then we're going to bring to the stage Todd sharer.
Uh,
Todd is the chief executive officer of the foundation.
Todd is formally trained as a neuroscientist and he now directs the
organization's research strategy as well.
He's responsible of course for the overall scientific and fundraising efforts.
Todd,
great to see you.
[inaudible]
how did I go back a ways.
But the cool thing is that I didn't realize until I read your bio is that you
received a grant from the foundation in 2003.
And so he was a grant recipient and then came in house to gradually assume
increasing responsibilities and now is the CEO of the organization.
So great to have you here.
Thanks Phil.
And then our very special guest,
Michael J.
Fox
[inaudible]
seem a little superfluous for me to provide a formal introduction,
but I will provide a very brief one.
As you know,
he is an actor,
producer,
and author and of course an advocate.
Uh,
they say you burst onto the scenes with iconic roles.
Alex p Keaton from NBC is family ties.
Marty McFly in the back to the future trilogy and,
and he's continued to thrill audiences as recently as uh,
the good wife and with his portrayal of Louis Canning.
But he's also a best selling author and he's written three books,
is that right?
Three,
three and a half.
Three and a half.
A lucky man,
a memoir,
always looking up the adventures of an incurable optimist and a funny thing
happened on the way to the future twists and turns and lessons learned.
I think you can tell a lot just about the,
the focus there.
He was diagnosed with Parkinson's in 1991 at the age of 29 and disclosed his
condition to the public in 1998 ultimately went on to fund the foundation in
2000 so warm welcome again for
Todd and Michael [inaudible].
Thanks to you both for being here.
It's really,
really kind of you to come and help our employees understand Parkinson's
disease.
You know,
Monterey to be here.
I just want to say I've said to a couple people,
but,
but I always think when I'm,
when I'm with a group like this,
I think your parents must be so disappointed.
Nothing.
Well,
you know,
it's been interesting,
Michael is when word leaked out that you might be visiting us.
I had a number of people come up to me and tell me that you are their hero,
their idol.
And I had to sort of smile because as a neurologist taking care of Parkinson's
patients for the last 20 years,
um,
they feel the same way about you,
that you've been their hero and idol.
And I just wonder,
did you ever think you'd be in that kind of a role?
No,
I didn't.
I didn't think,
I didn't see it through eight.
It's kind of like the,
when I get to work,
when I got into acting just as a thing that felt good to me.
And so I did it and it,
and it,
and it turned out.
But when I found,
when I was diagnosed with Parkinson's,
I didn't,
my first thought was other people.
My first of what the hell happened to me,
what am I going to do?
And,
and,
and it took about seven years for me to work that all out.
And then,
and then what happened was when,
once I accepted that,
and I've said people,
but acceptance is,
is,
uh,
my happiness grows in direct proportion to my acceptance,
an inverse proportion,
the expectation,
it what,
what,
what if I could just accept what my situation is,
then I can move in,
I can nuance it and I can,
I can be honest about it and I can,
I can move forward.
And also I B,
I felt 10,
oh,
became part of a community and an undue or other people and that they were in
the same situation I was.
And they had thoughts and feelings are similar mine and,
and goals and,
and,
and hopes that was similar to mine.
And I stopped.
The only difference is I'm in this unique position in this position where people
know me and have a predisposition towards me,
whether it's good or bad,
mostly good,
which was nice.
And,
and,
um,
and so I said,
I have an opportunity here and I can't have a responsibility here to do
something.
And so the foundation was born,
but I,
the gratitude that you say that people expressed toward me and,
and,
and most feelings are completely mutual.
I mean,
it's,
so I'm so inspired by people that have this and they're in a tougher position
than I am and they deal with the daily and,
and,
and I feel honored that they've been trusted me with their,
their hopes and their dreams of,
of,
of being rescued.
Well,
you've already gotten pretty personal and I wanted to go back in time to,
uh,
no.
Uh,
um,
back to the first symptoms.
Um,
what were you experiencing?
I was doing a movie in Florida called Doc Hollywood and I was not,
I was,
I woke up in the morning,
I had twitching pinky and I,
I,
I've got that night before with Woody Harrelson was on the movie and that's
always bad news.
And so we kind of ripped up jeans go.
We were in a college town would be like,
what are you here after going to college?
This is all bad.
Um,
but,
but uh,
so I put up the next morning I had this twitching pinky and I couldn't,
I couldn't stop it.
It just kept twitching.
And so I went to,
I went to,
um,
they're all just on the campus right away.
Yeah.
I went and I went and I said,
did you see what right?
Cause I thought I hit my owner or it,
and he said,
the guy said it was drastic,
drastic.
It was some poll and,
and uh,
he completely missed the boat.
But I mean there's so symptoms with,
with early onset,
they really tell you I need a 29 year old guy.
He's not to get Parkinson's.
So then about a year later,
a year later,
you're lighter.
I found myself,
I'm in the wrong office because I had gone to a physical therapist who said this
is neurological,
the neurologist's office.
And He,
I did the battery of tests.
I mean to sell today.
It's,
so we haven't got biomarker.
We ended up waiting to identify it.
So you do this drunk driving tests and which I failed.
And,
and,
um,
and then he sat me down and said,
you have Parkinson's,
Parkinson's disease and you have 10 years left to work in.
And it was just wham.
And,
and I,
it took me a long time that I remember going outside and leaving the doctor's
office and,
and,
uh,
it was just this rainy day in New York and they just thought how this happened.
I mean,
and I even had,
I have to confess,
I had feelings.
I don't,
you know who I am.
You get parents that I have,
Parkinson's is not the script.
And,
um,
uh,
so,
so that was being my journey.
It must've been a stunning thing to here.
It was pretty shocking.
And then I told my wife,
I came home,
told my wife and,
and he just was like,
uh,
we have young son is two,
he's 27 now.
But he was,
he was,
he was really young and he just said,
we didn't know what the future.
But I,
I've always been,
uh,
if not optimistic,
I tend to look at things positively.
And,
and,
and I knew that there was something in there all the way along the first few
years,
I knew that there was something to fit this was,
there's possibility in here and there,
those was,
there was opportunity to,
to change the way I look at things at very least in adapting to it.
And something good might come about.
Were you treated with medication right away?
Once the diagnosis was given medication,
but I treat it like smarties.
I just throw my pocket.
If I was feeling twitchy,
I'd pop a pill in it.
And I really did it haphazardly in and had dyskinesia as a result.
I had been swaying movements even early on.
Yeah,
yeah.
From the,
from the drugs that I take too much.
Yeah.
And I,
and it,
cause I wasn't,
I didn't educate myself,
but the disease and then about four or five years in,
I started just really talk to my doctor and I kind of,
I had,
this isn't going away,
this and I haven't like changed toothpaste and have something better and got
toothpaste all along
was he knew that it was then it was in it.
And I had to educate myself about it.
And so I did.
And so that brought me to a place where,
where before it started the foundation,
I was,
um,
I was in Washington testifying about the need for funding and,
and I talked to doctors who said the science is of the money.
They've kept saying to me,
if the science is ahead of the money,
I thought,
well,
that's what I chased the science.
I mean,
it's like kind of flip on the Watergate thing.
It's my father's side.
It's fault,
the money and the money will follow the science and,
and,
um,
and so that kind of getting into my head and I just knew that it needed to treat
this like a business and treat it well,
treat it like,
like,
uh,
our,
our goals throughout the business.
And we need to,
we need to look at it from a scientific point of view,
from a business point of view,
from an academic point of view,
from a patient point of view.
And,
and,
and we managed to do that.
Before you went public,
you had a felon autonomy,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
Before,
I'm a republican and a foul anatomy is a very precise therapeutic lesioning
procedure of area of the brain that's generating the tremor.
It's 20th century Triponin.
How did you decide to do that?
I had huge symptoms on my left side and I was doing a show called spin city and
I was finding myself doing scenes.
US standing on my hands,
you're going to just wouldn't stop.
And it just was,
I mean,
everything I did was I was acting and I was doing my job,
but I was also involved in Ms Direction and,
and started hand in and just finding ways to lean on deaths and,
and if have to tip my tremor,
if I,
if I did something it would,
it would rest.
So if I,
if I move this,
so I would like be doing a scene and I just do that for a reason.
And um,
and so I thought,
I talked to some neurologists and I said,
we can diminish the tremor on that side by doing the small incision and your
thumb on me and your thalamus.
It's called the tell mommy.
And,
um,
so I did it and,
and it,
and it worked.
It helped.
But then it started on my right side so I wasn't going to go back in again.
And,
um,
it was,
it was a stop gap measure that,
that I don't know that I would do it again,
but I don't,
I don't resent the fact that I did it.
I don't always have the doctors that did.
I don't regret it,
but,
but I,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't do it again because they're going to,
I mean,
the next time we went,
my brain being a habit figured out.
Todd,
you're a neuroscientist.
How did you become interested in working on Parkinson's disease?
Um,
I was fooled into working in Parkinson's disease because at the,
uh,
at the time when I was in graduate school,
and still one of the common theories in Parkinson's is that there's really a
selective loss of a very specific population of cells in the brain that produce
dopamine in the substantia Nigra.
And at the time of diagnosis,
it's believed that already 80% or so of those cells have degenerated before the
symptoms start.
So as a naive graduate student,
I thought,
well,
wouldn't be so hard to just save 10% of these cells and then we'd have cured
Parkinson's.
And of course we know it's much more complicated than that.
But just sorta like the academic challenge of that drew me into this to really,
it's a seems to be a very solvable disease if we can push the science and fund
the right science.
And so you were a grant recipient of the foundation just a few years into its
creation and then how did you end up becoming staff?
It's really hard being a grant recipient of the foundation.
It's much easier being the grant giver.
But actually one of the things that really impressed me when I had my grant was
that the foundation is very focused on accountability.
And as having a fellowship from the,
from the foundation,
I still had to come in and report on what I actually use the money for,
which is not actually that common in the granting industry.
And what was really exciting about that is I actually got to meet the other
grant recipients and it really improved my research.
And,
um,
develop this network and I got access to new tools and it got me really excited
about this new way of funding and pushing research forward.
And at that time when Michael and Debbie were expanding the activities to look
to bring on internal scientists and to have that opportunity to have this broad
impact across the whole disease rather than just be focusing on one,
you're one molecule to your one project
was really exciting to me.
Michael,
can you describe a typical day with Parkinson's disease if there is such a
thing?
Well,
I don't have any typical days,
but in general,
I mean I don't,
I don't go to work at the same place every day now,
so,
so I never knew what to expect on any given day.
And I have my,
I have commitments or responsibilities in,
Oh,
titrate my medication according to what I want to have to do.
I don't take pills at nine o'clock and 1130 and I have kind of areas that I,
and some days I feel better if I come to California if feel a lot better than
I've seen in New York.
High pressure's better for me than a low pressure.
Um,
humanities for me,
if I eat protein,
it's,
it's tough for me.
So I'm always doing different things.
But,
but,
um,
I typical days I get up and,
and,
and I literally,
someone once said to me that it used to be the hero's journey was to slay the
dragon and saved the princess.
But for me,
he was,
journey is pretty much put in front of the other and getting out of bed.
And literally since I've,
I've had this problem with gait and with falling,
I literally get up and okay,
and okay,
and it's,
it's again,
you look at things differently and I look at that as this is an incredible gift.
I think that is that to,
to live that metaphor is,
is,
is so rewarding and enlightening and just opens you up to,
to,
to everything.
Because it really is about that step.
And I don't know what to expect after that.
Like we were header into the toilet and crack my handover.
So,
so,
and let the possibility and the next moment,
so I get to read and I don't do that,
then that's a success.
I can build on that.
And um,
my,
my day is a typical day is just building and building on,
uh,
relationships and being open to it,
to my family and how they react to it and realizing if it affects them too.
And,
um,
and again,
this,
the only thing that in this understanding that no one dies from Parkinson's,
you die with Parkinson's.
And so I'm,
I'm,
I'm living with Parkinson's and,
and my family's living room,
the two.
And so I respond to,
to how they,
how they react and,
and,
and I respond to how I'm feeling and just,
uh,
it's why this,
this,
this work is,
is so rewarding because it's,
it gives me,
it gives me a,
a feeling of,
of usefulness and then I'm,
then I'm doing something productive.
It's really common for people with Parkinson's to talk about how difficult it is
in the morning since they've gone all night without medication.
Do you find you can count on your beds once you have taken them?
Yeah,
but I liked his butt played this game.
I put Skim,
keep away with them.
I I could care less forestall as where they can.
Um,
but why,
why is that?
It just because it'll go,
cause I can,
I can,
if I can pump up.
That's right.
You don't have to take it at eight and I take,
take it at nine 30,
then I don't have to take you up to,
and I'm good in the evening.
Um,
it's,
it's funny to be,
I try not to be a prisoner to it.
I tried to,
to,
to be,
uh,
to have it be a living relationship between me and my treatment that we give and
take.
Right.
And,
um,
uh,
you know,
any,
he played games that we got,
I was saying to someone earlier and when I go to my doctors and my movement
disorder specialist and she,
she's doing this kind of comes in with this,
uh,
information,
devices that you guys are working on.
Um,
I go in and,
and she has a list of questions about how I'm doing and she has a graph from one
to five or zero to five.
So,
so I,
I instinctually want to get those Zeros,
which means I'm not,
I'm not,
I don't have the symptoms that she's talking about typical over achiever,
right?
Yeah.
But I didn't have the symptoms,
but I say,
you know,
I say I met up so I'm really good shape and I,
and I do my walking really well and I do my,
all my stuff really well and she's like,
you're great.
And I'm like,
not really,
but,
and this is a key point where you're pointing out is,
is the snapshot that the doctor gets in the office doesn't necessarily what's
going on at Mcdonnell and,
and,
and where we are in many ways the best reporters of our situation or condition.
But in other ways we're not because we just pure humanity,
human instinct to want to be the best you can be at any given moment.
So the idea that there's a device that you can just hand you a doctor and he or
she gets a run rundown of what your day,
your week,
your month has been.
How are you,
Hey,
you movement is responding to medication.
How,
how,
how much rest you need.
And I mean,
it's an amazing,
amazing thought that you can,
you can,
you can turn your experience into,
into information that,
that helps people that are there,
uh,
in a position to do something about it.
Question for you.
People may notice a little bit of the writhing movement that you have,
the Dyskinesia.
Can you comment on what,
what that's like and what,
it's
almost when you're,
the focus of attention,
uh,
get you,
get you Twitty.
So it's just a,
it's a,
it's,
it's a reaction to the medication.
There's something that this drug that I take for called Amantadine,
which is a found drug,
like many drugs that treat diseases that don't have cures or,
or therapies that pretty much resemble a cure.
Um,
and so it made it in,
this was a drug that was used for old people had flu and it happens to diminish
Dyskinesia,
but it's going to harsh and even,
I mean,
after a while you see spiders in the corner and stuff moving that isn't there.
Um,
so,
so it's,
is trade off with everything.
You try to do a little of that as possible.
I mean,
I could,
I could get myself still,
but it would be the expensive,
my articulate,
my articulation in my Todd.
I think Michael's bringing up one of the clinical
issues is the motor fluctuation,
the trying to balance the good function without being too slow or too
diskinetic.
Um,
are,
are there efforts that the foundation has supported to try to help with some of
these day to day symptomatic needs?
Yeah,
there's a lot of research going on in this area.
One of the main areas is to just see if we can get a better standard delivery of
the medication.
So that Michael was talking before about how he's trying to time his medication
throughout the day to have the optimal benefit.
But there's a lot of research to just try to see if you could reformulate the
medication either with a patch delivery or more rapid onset delivery just so you
can get a more continuous,
consistent,
more predictable day.
And a lot of that is driven by the disease,
but also by how your body is handling this medication.
One,
a comment that Michael made was repurposing drugs and I think it's been really
brilliant what one of your programs has done,
if you want to describe that.
Yeah,
this is a big effort,
not just in Parkinson's,
but an effort we focused on,
which is there's a lot of commonalities in the underlying biological mechanisms
across disease.
And you could take advantage of some of the innovations that have been made to
develop molecules or compounds in other diseases and now apply and test them in
Parkinson's.
Right now there's a large trial going on looking at blood pressure medication as
actually a treatment for Parkinson's because the same calcium channels are
involved in,
in the nervous system.
So there's a lot of efforts.
This is the whole point of this to try to short circuit some of the slowness of
the drug development pipeline and take advantage of existing treatments and
apply them to the disease.
And Michael,
was that your intent in creating the foundation to,
to you know,
find new drugs or find a cure or all the above or started that to finding a cure
but then it,
it,
we,
we realized that they're doing no pathways to the queue.
There's silos,
but they're very few
thruways pipelines.
And,
and,
um,
so we,
as we evolved,
we found,
we found ourselves with a whole new issue,
which was finding drugs and therapies and improving what was there and
incentivizing drug companies to,
to take us on because we had a million,
we're,
we're a relatively small population,
uh,
of,
of
sufferers or people that have it.
And,
and,
and so,
uh,
we,
we would,
we have a drug company and we'd say we're going on a compound and introduced it
and we,
we lend a multibillion dollar,
give a multibillion dollar corporation,
$5 million to try to keep your eye on the,
on the,
on the ball.
And then,
then we,
then we inserted some situation with big follow on funding once,
once those results were good.
And,
and,
um,
he,
she said,
I mean,
I credit these guys with it.
He came up with it and,
and,
and it's been amazing.
Our,
she put Pharma who,
I always kind of thought it was bad guys,
but,
but we went away to work with them and then have good results.
Have the goals of the foundation changed from when you first envisioned it to
what your,
what you think is important now or do you feel there's a certain concept?
Let's see.
I,
I didn't see that we do so much.
Uh,
uh,
just fine.
He's just finding new ways to,
to approach it.
And I thought it was,
I thought it was you find scientists and you fund them,
but,
but it's bigger than that.
It's funding scientists and,
and knowing what you want to,
what you want from them.
And that's one of the reasons that they tell you about accountability.
We,
I,
I remember saying in early meetings when you give this got $2 million and he's
not going to come and tell us what he's doing.
I mean,
I want a report,
I want to give them a report card I want to enter into and withhold funding.
If not,
it's not going in a direction that we expected.
So this philosophy came from the top,
it sounds like.
Well,
I,
I kind of,
I'm like Chauncey Gardner and being there,
I just going to spout
no endowment.
Money comes in,
money goes out,
or I would just look a little Colin's and it,
and the Deb translates into policy.
Yeah,
no,
this is fascinating.
So you said money comes in,
money goes out,
there was no endowment.
You raise the money each year and you spend it.
Yeah,
I mean that's what it's there for.
Yeah.
It's that we're not,
we don't want,
we don't want to like sit on a pile of money.
I mean,
it's not doing anybody any good.
So,
so it goes in,
it goes down and,
um,
science hadn't the money and,
and uh,
and I can't think of a million others,
but,
so I just kind of,
um,
feel confident that we were going in,
in,
in an innovative direction and we're doing it in a new way,
but just see what all you are about.
Speaking of innovative directions,
Todd,
can you give us a sense of the scope of work that the foundation has supported
and is supported over the years?
Yeah,
so,
um,
I mean we leave no stone unturned,
but,
uh,
we are focused on really developing new treatments.
A lot of this is now coming out of really novel genetic discoveries.
Parkinson's in the past wasn't thought to have much of a genetic component,
but we're now uncovering a lot of the molecular biology and underlying science
to develop new treatments.
So there's a lot of work the foundation does to build that knowledge base around
these new targets and directions and early drug discovery and more importantly
now we're doing additional work on really how going to go and test these
therapies to see if they're actually working.
Michael was talking about the,
the exam that is done that involves tapping your nose and tapping your feet and
then the doctor gives you a one or a two.
This is the,
the whole basis of a multimillion dollar clinical trial is based on those
outcomes.
So there's a big effort the foundation has on trying to improve the outcome
measures that could be used in trials both biologically and clinically with some
more of the eject objective measures.
And the other thing that I think is important is to get a better handle on
really the natural history of the disease and the variability of the disease
that the foundation's working on.
You asked Michael what his typical day is.
There's also not a typical Parkinson's patient,
so you have varied patients having varied types of days.
So we need to make more sense of this again so we could really understand how
the drugs are working and that's a big effort.
The foundation has this baseline that then all the companies and all the drug
developers can build on top of this is Ppmi.
You're Ppmi right?
Just talk a little bit more about what Ppmi is as a Ppmi is the Parkinson's
progression markers initiative that is a large scale,
um,
natural history study of Parkinson's and people at risk for developing
Parkinson's.
It's in 35 sites throughout the world and has rigorous clinical data,
biological data that's collected genetics,
neuroimaging,
and it's developed as an open platform.
So all the data is made available in real time.
It's a collaborative between the academics and the pharmaceutical companies that
is spearheaded through the foundation.
And the goal of this is to really establish a new framework for how we would do
clinical trials,
particularly trials of drugs that would slow the disease.
We talked before about treatments that could reduce some of the symptoms,
but ultimately we want a treatment that can slow the progress of the disease.
And in that case we need to have a better understanding of how the disease is
actually progressing both clinically and biologically.
We're going to open it up for questions soon,
but I wonder,
Todd,
if you had thoughts about what an organization like verily might contribute to
advancing the field.
As you know,
this is a room full of hardware engineers,
software engineers,
computational biologists,
clinicians,
clinical researchers,
and so many more types of people,
basic scientists,
uh,
w w what can we do to help?
I think the,
that can be done here is really would be fundamental to how we can change our
potential for developing transformative treatments for Parkinson's.
Where we now are in a position where we have a,
an ability to collect a vast amount of data from people with Parkinson's at the
extent never before.
And if you think about the study I just talked about the PPMI initiative,
we have whole genome sequencing,
we have brain imaging,
we have proteomics,
RNA sequencing,
clinical data,
all being collected over time.
We would love to have obviously more objective clinical data.
So using technology to track the course of a day.
So it's not just that half hour with a doctor to get the clinical sense,
but then how are we going to utilize all of this information and data to make
sense of the disease?
So it's,
we have the input happening,
how do we now sort of make that output,
the analytics and really the innovation on that information.
And I think that the kind of personnel that are here feed into all of those
components that are critical to really take Parkinson's from 1817 to 2017.
I agree.
I'm going to wrap up my questions with two of them and I've a feeling you're
going to want to answer them,
uh,
with the,
optimistic answer last.
So I'll,
I'll start with the more pessimistic one.
What have you been frustrated by?
What,
what hasn't really materialized in the last 10 years,
years.
Oh,
well,
I mean cure
you guys do,
we're going to lift where and,
and uh,
uh,
devices that,
that,
that did help a Parkinson's patient live on a day to day basis and,
and,
and just be normal,
feel normal.
So liftware is spoons that neutralize tremor and it's really great stuff.
And,
and I was saying earlier that the issues that I deal with,
uh,
like,
was walking,
she just got fascination where you,
your,
your footsteps get so synchronized that you get to a point where you're frozen
and then you tip over like a tree.
There's nothing you can do about it.
Um,
but there are tricks you can do counting or are you have your shoulders back
and,
and making big steps.
But it's just all this thinking you have to do all the time to do this in,
in,
so I saw you doing it and I have a hallway in my house.
I go around a corner and there's a door to the hall,
to the Hallway.
There's a door to my closet,
which is just around the thing and then the door to my office,
which is next door.
So I have to work on these doors and I had to put tape down on the floor so I
could step over the tape.
So it would remind me to take a step and tonight get shoveled and falling of the
closet.
And my wife,
I said,
I really love you but can we get rid of the frigging tape?
I can't wipe out.
And that's to me it seems like a simple thing to,
to to to some way deal with,
uh,
to,
to look down and create a beam for yourself that it's discreet and invisible to
anyone else at me.
You step over it,
I mean kind of stuff you guys do.
Um,
just,
just to,
to,
we offered the reality in a way that,
that,
that you can function and,
and I'm,
and it short of a cure that,
that kind of stuff it really valuable and really important.
You talked about some of your frustrations on the flip side,
where do you most proud of in terms of your work in Parkinson's advocacy?
Mommy's the happy guy.
I mean,
I just,
I just look at life as endless opportunity and I'm way wake up every day.
Curious and,
and,
and I think that that's as important as anything to wake up every day and say,
well,
what is this taking to bring me?
What is it they get to bring us?
What are the possibilities in this day and what,
what,
where,
where outcomes.
And I might,
I might see,
uh,
again,
I,
I live in acceptance and not an expectation,
but acceptance isn't resignation.
It's,
it's,
it's just acknowledging the truth and being empowered by it.
[inaudible]
I think we have time for some questions,
so we'd love to open it up to the audience.
We have some microphones in the center aisle.
Feel free to ask questions of Michael Todd.
Debbie.
Hi,
how are you?
I'm Vanessa.
I'm in the science team.
I'm work with microbiome and I had a couple of questions not related to
microbiome.
And so,
um,
in diabetes,
right,
we have a pump and you have the glucose monitor and so you can handle titrate
your insulin treatment depending on your glucose in your blood.
So I was wondering if,
um,
if you could try trade the treatment depending on your physical symptoms.
So if you had like for example,
this watch that is monitoring your movements through the day,
would that inform,
um,
how you would titrate your therapy?
And on that note,
what are the challenges of using things like the equivalent of an insulin pump
or a patch for therapy?
Uh,
dis giving therapy to the patients,
Todd and Michael.
Yeah,
so I'll start.
He bill could help too.
Um,
so I think first the answer is,
uh,
in terms of having an objective measure and titrating your medicine,
the answer would be that would be a goal.
One of the challenges we have is in the diabetes example,
you're actually measuring a realtime Bob biologic impact of the drug.
So that is a need in Parkinson's still to understand more of the biology and
have a biomarker.
But we could use a objective measure of the motor symptoms.
And if the patient could start to identify when they think their medication's
starting to wear off objectively,
they could actually preemptively take the medicine so that instead of a patient
maybe going like this during the day with their medicine,
if you could kind of see I'm about to go off take your pills.
So as that kicks in,
you never hit that trough.
I think that is a real possibility with the technology.
Um,
in terms of the delivery of the drug,
the real challenge with the pumps have been just the biochemistry of Levodopa,
which is the medicine that the patients use,
the dosing that's needed and being able to formulate enough of it into a pump
that would sort of last the entirety of the day.
And that is,
uh,
there's projects that are working on that now.
Um,
but so I think there's a lot of parallels,
just more research would be needed to get to the implication
of that.
Do you really want to screw around with all that stuff?
I mean,
looking at watches and I mean,
this is me,
it's just simple.
It's simpler than sitting there for,
for we're half an hour.
And I'm grateful that my doctor gives me a half an hour.
Most patients don't get that.
But yeah,
I been to to,
to just to just have an,
uh,
have a,
an impartial,
just factual record of what you're experiencing and to,
and to have someone be able to look that graphic,
to hear your problem areas,
here's where you're having difficult transitions and then,
and then,
uh,
adjust the medication accordingly.
Because I answered questions about my typical day and I didn't say that,
but that's the thing.
Typical Day is managing,
it's managing symptoms and you do everything else around that.
And um,
uh,
it can't see it's tiring and exhausting or annoying or frustrating or saddening
or maddening or anything.
It just is,
again,
it's this idea of the fact of it.
It just,
it is so,
so,
so that's my thing I work on all days is how am I going to get to a place today
that I want to be when I'm comfortable.
Wow.
Did you just said this is what you work on all day?
Yeah,
but it's,
but it's kind of like,
it's kind of like walking,
you're breathing.
It's just,
it's just the thing that I do and it's added to my,
to my portfolio.
Would I need to do on a given day?
Another question.
Sorry,
Tom.
My name's Tom.
I'm on the mental health team here and,
um,
we need to talk.
We do this.
That's what I wanted to ask you about.
Thanks for coming for all of you from the foundation.
We really appreciate your insights.
In addition to the kinds of devices that we work on,
we think a lot here about big data and analytics and how to find patterns in
very noisy but often important data.
Michael,
I was impressed by your story about putting the tape on the floor.
Most everything you've talked to us about is ways you found to cope and to deal
with this disease so that you can continue to function.
And I suspect there,
uh,
another million people with the same disease who also have tricks that they've
found,
sometimes even medications that they may have found that they're taking for
asthma or for some other problem that surprisingly helps them with their
symptoms.
Does the foundation have a way of crowdsourcing that information pulling in from
a million people and their families what works,
what doesn't?
And then people like us can help to make sense of that.
Is that something that the foundation thinks about?
Why do it under general?
I was talking about how we're specifically doing that,
but,
but one of the big breakthroughs in this,
someone was asking me earlier,
but one of the,
what are the big breakthroughs in the foundation?
One of our big breakthroughs was finding a way to incorporate patient
involvement and patient knowledge and wisdom and enthusiasm and,
and,
um,
and in fact,
it,
it's about these people in so they can,
they can help us with what we're trying to do.
And,
and,
um,
uh,
so all those,
those things I find really fascinating when I talked to Kip Parsons patients is
we don't,
we all have different disease.
1 million of us,
we were a million versions of it.
We have things that we,
that we,
uh,
have difficulty with that someone asked me and I deal with it all.
Um,
I,
I don't,
I mean gastro gastro intestinal stuff is that I don't have that.
We had an issue with that.
Um,
I've never had an issue with,
I,
until recently didn't have an issue with sleeping,
but,
um,
so,
so there's back and forth between patients really helps doctors and researchers.
Yeah.
So more exactly based on this philosophy where in the process of launching,
which is just getting started up a project called Fox insight,
which is an online platform for patients to sort of do exactly this,
to collect information from as many patients as we can and have them complete
surveys and also fill out information to just get more insights and a kind of
concern,
you know,
come confined way on this information and the data will all be made available
from that for people to dig into both surveys and free text and that type of
information.
So we see this as kind of complimentary to the PPMI initiative is a small number
of people and really deep and this would be as many people as we could get,
but more sort of superficial kind of information and then playing those two off
of each other to get in as much insights as we can.
That's the question.
Hi,
my name is James.
I'm a scientist who also works in the same department with our microbiome expert
over here.
But to follow up on her question about therapy,
it sounds like you and maybe a lot of other Parkinson's sufferers also have a
pretty complicated relationship with their therapy,
with their therapy that they're taking their medications.
And I'm wondering is,
is compliance with the therapy or the Richmond a challenge that is faced when
trying to interpret information coming off of clinical trial or even to manage
the disease?
Um,
and are there solutions that you guys are looking at that might be a way to
amend that problem?
So maybe a two part question.
The first for Michael,
is it a,
how difficult it is?
Is it to manage the medication schedule each day?
I mean,
it's difficult,
but again,
it's about someone who's a paraplegic has difficulties.
I mean,
there's all kinds of,
everybody gets arrested today issues and,
and I'm aware of that.
And then it's how you deal with them,
uh,
the how you deal with them as an individual thing.
And so,
uh,
I,
I struggle sometimes with getting it right for the most part.
If I,
if I can function and do what I planned to do during the course of the day.
It's great.
I mean there's,
there's things that like I golf and,
and I'm a terrible golfer.
I started golfing my forties with Parkinson's,
so that's not optimism.
I don't know what it is,
but,
but I was golfing in the day and,
and I'll,
I'll get 50 tee on the ball and I'll be like,
they're literally five minutes putting on it falls off,
it falls off.
I put on in Florida by just the tea,
I put her on,
her phone was off,
I put the ball on slow,
I'd get my hand away quicker.
It's foam up and there's three guys waiting and,
and,
and let's just talk him.
It take as long as it takes me to get volunteers and then swinging it and miss
it twice.
So,
so it's the hanging in the one day.
Um,
and it's just,
it's just what it is.
So,
um,
so I,
I do deal with titrating the meds,
but,
but it's just the way it is.
I think in general,
Parkinson's patients compared to other diseases are pretty compliant with their
medicine because they feel the impact of it.
It's not like for example,
taking it like a high blood pressure pill where Renee antibiotic,
if you forgot to take it,
you don't really realize you forgot to take it.
Michael will realize if he forgot to take as many timing may be off or the,
but it's not like he's not taking it at all.
So
any closing thoughts that you would offer the group today?
Um,
I mean I guess just to reiterate,
uh,
are thankful.
Thank [inaudible] thank you for including us in their grand rounds and for your
commitment to Parkinson's disease.
And I do think that for us to take the research to the next level,
which ultimately the goal is to bring the treatments to the next level.
We'll take this new approach of bringing new disciplines into the area.
And I think the model here is a great one for the field to be following and
integrating because that will really bring us to the breakthroughs that we want.
So thank you for all the work you're doing.
And Parkinson's.
Thanks Todd and Michael.
And He,
thank you.
I mean,
thank you so much for your interest and for your,
for a applying your,
your intellect to our situation.
And um,
it just,
it just for understanding that,
oh,
I'm here to do a separate from Todd who can speak program and science.
It's,
well,
you know,
that,
that it,
that you're affecting patients,
you're affecting people.
And then they have my experiences,
my experience,
but they have no experience in and,
and yet common bond between all of us.
We depend on other people and we depend on other researchers.
We depend on smart,
empathetic people that,
that they can figure out what we need and help us get there.
And I'm,
I'm,
I'm grateful for you,
for your interest and for your actions.
We're very grateful that you visited us today and thanks for your inspirational
comments.
[inaudible].